alright, we're back at it with part 2.
we're talking about race again here.
Emily is asking how she,
as a white woman,
can empower and motivate people of color,
all because as a leader,
she wants to nurture a diverse culture.
and I am so proud of her for asking.
if you haven't seen part one,
go ahead and watch this video all the way through.
get all of these points,
and then go back and watch part one.
number 4 is very direct.
so know my heart.
know my heart when I say this.
okay? if you are a white person
and you wanna do the right thing,
you wanna be an ally,
or you want to have the right heart posture,
and you want to do the right thing
by empowering people in the workplace,
still understand that people of color
don't need you to be their savior.
this is not an opportunity for you to get a
diversity pad on the back.
that's. that's not what this should be.
understand that
you should be trying to do the right thing
just for the sake of doing the right thing
and having integrity.
this is not an opportunity for you to
be somebody savior.
so that's another opportunity
to make sure that your heart is right.
why am I saying this?
because the reality is,
a lot of people of color are very empowered.
a lot of people
are very encouraged and motivated.
and so you're coming
in to be a part of the support system,
not a savior.
let me know in the comments if that would make sense.
number 5 is understanding that everything
doesn't have to be a race thing.
it doesn't always have to be you being a white leader,
empowering people of color.
the goal should really be
to be a good leader across the board,
a servant leader across the board
to everybody.
so just know that
it doesn't always have to be about race.
next is, as a leader,
you want to develop some
standard practices and policies,
align your actions with the company policies,
and make sure that you are consistent across the board.
you're not showing any type of favoritism.
that alone will keep you out of trouble.
when it comes to interacting with other races.
just make sure that you treat everybody the same.
you treat everybody with respect.
you give everybody opportunities.
you celebrate everybody.
be consistent.
number 7 is
you want to build rapport
while respecting boundaries.
and when you're building rapport with people of color,
you don't have to develop a black scent.
don't, don't.
don't be yourself, okay?
you don't have to pretend to be what you think black is.
to relate to black people.
just know that
last, but certainly not least,
is to simply ask them how you can support them.
this is a standard practice
that you can use in leadership.
you have to ask people.
everyone is not the same.
everyone views support
completely different.
some examples would be
what are one or 2 things you want me to keep doing
as your leader?
and what are one or 2 things you want me to stop doing?
then have humility
and be able to accept what they say.
I hope this helps.